bonjour et bienvenue dans europe et dont
nous sommes dans l'hémicycle du
parlement européen à bruxelles
dans cette émission direction la grèce
avec un grand reportage où nous verrons
que la fraude fiscale est là bas non
seulement un sport national mais surtout
la règle la grèce qui n'a toujours pas
reçu l'argent promis par l'europe
dernier plan avant la faillite c'est la
question de la semaine
nouvelle réunion de crise en europe les
ministres des finances sont une fois de
plus au chevet de la grèce la zone euro
tremble athènes vient d'annoncer une
nouvelle dégradation de ses finances
publiques le gouvernement n'a plus
d'argent pour rembourser la dette
astronomique du pays
en clair l'état ne pourra plus payer ses
fonctionnaires
la catastrophe est annoncée
réaction immédiate sur les grandes
places boursières à londres paris milan
ou new york par tous les cours chutent
côté politique la réponse est beaucoup
plus lente la réunion du 13 octobre qui
était crucial pour l'aide à la grèce a
été annulé et repoussé au 13 novembre
un mois plus tard toujours pas de
décision à l'horizon mais sur les
marchés la rumeur dit que la faillite de
la grèce est proche
face à l'urgence le président de la zone
euro jean claude juncker reste serein
no14 du photographe en grèce la colère
gronde
les experts de l'union européenne et du
fonds monétaire international demande au
peuple de faire encore des efforts en
échange de l'aide financière promise
mais faute d'accord dans la zone euro
l'argent tarde à arriver un nouveau plan
d' aide à la grèce a été décidée le 21
juillet dernier
il n'est toujours pas adopté à ce jour
et plus les européens attendent plus la
dette grecque grossi avec pour horizon
la banqueroute
mais à ce train là le plan européen
pourrait bien être le dernier avant la
faillite
retour à bruxelles au parlement européen
où les députés européens siège en ce
moment nous avons avec jean marie cavada
bonjour à vous vous êtes député européen
du groupe ppe le parti majoritaire ici
alors on joue à la situation s'aggrave
en grèce on sera dans quelques instants
à athènes pour tenter de comprendre ce
qui se passe athènes aujourd'hui au bord
de la faillite
expliquez nous pourquoi finalement les
européens mettent autant de temps à
attendre pour aider pour aider la grèce
alors qu'elle qu'elle a besoin de cet
argent je crois qu'il ya deux effets
différents il ya un effet d'abord
mécanique le temps de la spéculation et
de la vitesse des attaques spéculatives
qui se fait pas centièmes de seconde sur
des machines des programmes
par ordinateur est un temps ultra rapide
c'est presque le temps de l'éclair et ça
ne fait qu'empirer puisque la confiance
n'est pas là puisque les solutions ne
sont pas là et puis il ya le temps
politique et le temps politique lui-même
a été allongée parce que déjà qui ne
peut pas être aussi rapide évidemment il
a été allongé parce que tout le monde
n'était pas d'accord le point très
important c'est l'attitude de
l'allemagne qui a quand même changé je
dirais son point de vue la semaine
dernière il faut saluer cet effort qui
est tout à fait remarquable et à et je
dirais que pour une fois plutôt offensif
et courageux de la part de madame merkel
et ses alliés monsieur schaüble
madame von der leyen et quelques uns et
l'opposition allemande qui a été dans
cette affaire est vraiment à la hauteur
des enjeux n'étaient pas à temps pour
les destinations du partenaire grecque
il ya quelques mois encore elle était
réticente à aider la grèce
oui alors moi je crois que de toute
façon les européens doivent être
réalistes lui la solidarité s'impose
on ne peut pas laisser un des membres
tomber non non pas que ce soit si
important c'est 2 et quelques pour cent
du produit intérieur brut européen mais
parce que ce sera un signal terrible que
chaque pays en difficulté va être lâché
dans la nature autrement dit y'a plus
qu'à spéculer à fond la caisse
et puis enfin les spéculateurs font de
l'argent et on peut compter sur les
européens pour qu'ils ne fassent rien ça
il faut casser cette affaire par une
je dirais décision de fédéralisme
économique de contrôle fédéral
financiers et même du temps qu'on y est
me semble-t-il budgétaire évidemment et
fiscale s quand vous parlez ainsi vous
voulez est-ce que vous pensez que les
européens sont prêts à ces changements
quand même qu'ils sont qui sont grandes
en vous dites que si le temps de la
décision est aussi lancée parce qu'on
avait des structures qu'il faut la
décision de l'accord de tout le monde
donc vous dites qu'il faut changer ça un
peu le mécanisme dont les opinions sont
lentes en effet c'est ce que vous avez
l'air de suggérer vous avez raison elles
sont lentes et les responsables
politiques du coup selon eux aussi parce
que il regarde un peu ce que pensent
leurs opinions en allemagne je vous fais
remarquer que probablement madame merkel
pour une fois est allé à contre-courant
d'une opinion qui est plutôt
majoritairement sceptiques sur l'aide à
la grèce l'allemagne a bien fait madame
merkel et le gouvernement
bien fait car par deux fois dans ces 70
dernières années le monde entier a aidé
l'allemagne et notamment l'europe la
dernière fois lors de la réunification
du mur la chute du mur de berlin
l'europe si elle veut avoir un destin ne
peut-être que unifié ne peut être que
solidaires et naturellement cette
solidarité à un prix pour tout le monde
pour les contribuables allemands france
etc
mais quand nous faisons nos emplettes en
vendant nos marchandises à la grèce nous
gagnons de l'argent les banques qui se
sont avancés en grèce ont gagné beaucoup
d'argent avec la grèce je vois pas
pourquoi elle ne serait pas au minimum
solidaire elle aussi la solidarité ça a
un prix
le contraire c'est un désastre absolu
pour tout le monde oui on vous dit les
banques doivent être mises à
contribution
et puis voilà on a l'impression que
cette crise pèse sur le contribuable
européen est ce que vous pensez que qui
va devoir payer encore plus cher pour
alors que la crise s'aggrave
il faut souhaiter le coût social pour le
contribuable alors il faut d'abord le
coût social c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas
de solution à la crise parce que
l'europe traîne les pieds parce qu'elle
tarde pas ce que j'aurais quand même
faire remarquer que les 60 à 70
milliards d'euros qui viennent de partir
en fumée ces quatre derniers mois sort a
des conséquences économiques et donc
social sur l'emploi et qu'il faut pas
traîner faut casser la spéculation
si c'est un prix à payer nous le
payerons nous devons le payer parce que
si nous ne faisons pas ça le prix à
payer ça bien plus catastrophiques et
par conséquent de deux manières social
économique social et puis politique les
extrêmes casseront ce qu'il reste de
l'europe et on ne peut pas vivre sans
europe dans la mondialisation nous
allons devenir un l'île de malte aussi
les maltais me pardonne dans la
mondialisation ne seront plus rien
donc nous n'avons pas le choix en fait
le choix de l'union depuis la fin des
années 40 depuis le nez 50 en gros et
notamment 57 le traité de rome fondateur
nous devons nous nous sommes enrichis
nous avons eu beaucoup de prospérité
s'il ya un prix à payer à la solidarité
faut pas hésiter à le payer
en gros vous dites c'est soit la
faillite soit le fédéralisme c'est ça le
choix pour le sait la faillite de
l'europe où le fédéralisme économique
financier budgétaire et fiscale qui
s'impose à tout de toute urgence et si
les 1000 des finances n'y arrive pas il
faut quand même un peu décrypter ce
qu'ils veulent c'est faire pression sur
la grèce pour qu'elle mette en place un
système de perception de l'impôt et
fiscales qui tienne la route
mais ça se fera pas en un mois
faut pas rêver ça va prendre deux trois
quatre ans par conséquent il faut aider
la grèce quitte à contrôler très
sévèrement l'organisation de ses
finances d'après mes informations quand
on regarde les comptes réels de la grèce
elle n'aura pas besoin d'argent avant le
mois de novembre la mi novembre
donc les ministres des finances ont
voulu faire pression pour la faire
attendre et c'est pour ça qu'ils n'ont
pas voulu aller un accord leur faire
attention faut pas jouer avec le feu
il faut qu'on voit une volonté politique
de dominer de traiter cette affaire pour
faire reculer le principal adversaire
qui n'est pas la grèce qui sont les
spéculateurs les spéculateurs et alors
autre affaire qui monte en ce moment
c'est cesser cette affaire dexia avec la
banque franco-belge qui semble être la
première victime de la crise est-ce
qu'il faut redouter ce que vous pensez
que ça peut être le point de départ de
quelque chose de plus grave une crise
bancaire plus large en euros caire est
toujours un doute et si on ne fait pas
les choses mais là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est engagé dans une solution qui
m'a l'air assez réaliste et notamment
quel est le problème très important dans
cette affaire
les actionnaires privés de cette
banquise ont déjà payé ces partis en
fumée il paye
et puis vont devoir rallonger s'ils
veulent rester au tour de table mais
tout ce qui concerne les crédits est en
fait les actifs pourris toxiques des
crédits accordés aux collectivités la
france a pris sa responsabilité par un
accord franco belge et comme vous savez
nous allons reconstruire une sorte de
structure de garantie comme ce fut le
cas pour le crédit lyonnais en france il
ya une vingtaine d'années qui
garantissent les actifs pourris donc les
dettes adossées d'une part sur la caisse
des dépôts et consignations d'autre part
sur les caisses d'epargne si ma mémoire
est bonne donc les choses sont son
prison merci beaucoup
jean marie cavada était l'invitée
d'europe edouard cette crise de la dette
inquiète le reste du monde
les déclarations alarmistes multiplient
venu
d'outre-atlantique mais aussi
d'outre-manche ou david cameron fait la
leçon à ses partenaires européens
regardez il y a très clairement un
problème dans la zone euro est à présent
cette zone monétaire aux paysans d'une
menace sur elle-même pour l'économie
britannique et pour l'économie mondiale
et les anc urgent d'agir
les européens ne se sont pas
complètement remis de la crise de 2007
depuis ils ne se sont jamais vraiment
occupé des difficultés qui ont menacé
leurs banques
cela se conjugue à ce qui ce passe en
grèce résultat l'union traversent une
crise financière qui fait peur au monde
entier depuis plusieurs mois pékin
paraît comme le sauveur d'une zone euro
dans la tourmente
multipliant les achats de dette
européenne partout où il passe le
premier ministre wen jiabao est reçu
avec le tapis rouge
car il arrive les bras chargés de
cadeaux il promet de soutenir les pays
en difficulté
c'est l'invité surprise du jour c'est
mythique avec neuf est en pologne ce
vendredi aux côtés des ministres des
finances de la zone euro
et c'est pour mettre la pression sur ses
partenaires qu'il a fait le déplacement
pour le secrétaire américain au trésor
et les temps que les dirigeants
européens se mettent d'accord et trouve
rapidement une solution à la crise voilà
pour cette sélection des télévisions
européennes et pour commenter ce zapping
christophe garage est avec nous bonjour
vous êtes rédacteur en chef adjoint
d'euros par le tv spécialiste des
questions européennes que vous suivez
depuis longtemps
les britanniques ont des mois c'est
assez fort à l'égard de
de leur partenaire et ce qu'ils ont
raison ce qu'ils sont bien placés de
faire la leçon à la zone euro une petite
observation déjà à préliminaire est ce
que bon c'est vrai aujourd'hui à une
crise sans précédent tout le monde le
sait est ce qu'il faut pour autant
rajouter des commentaires assassins
est ce qu'il est nécessaire de remettre
une louche
à chaque fois qu'on le peut à chaque
fois qu'un micro se dresse devant soit
après ce que font les britanniques
travaillent moins ils sont pas les seuls
ils sont pas les seuls alors pourquoi
les britanniques c'est vrai les
britanniques ont un gros souci c'est que
la crise de la zone euro menace un
intérêt stratégique pour les
britanniques c'est la city et donc les
britanniques défendent leurs intérêts et
ils reviennent vers les européens en
leur demandant clairement d'agir bon
cela dit ces déclarations ces coups de
poing sur la table ça pourrait se faire
à huit clos en conseil européen en
devant la halle au conseil conseil
ecofin conseil de l'économie et des
finances des ministres la dea les
ministres européens très bien pourquoi
s'est pas fait à huis clos
on tape le poids on se dit des choses et
puis dehors on essaye d'avoir un ton
commun une voix qui essaye de calmer les
marchés pour l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas chacun y va de sa petite phrase
et la vérité c'est que ça ne contribue
qu'à une chose à entretenir le malaise
des services des mâts des marchés
financiers à entretenir aussi la
cacophonie au sein des dirigeants
européens
finalement les britanniques david
cameron en ayant des toners de pareils
propos regarde son intérêt comme
toujours au détriment de l'intérêt
européen
voilà c'est la vraie question la
sempiternelle question
cameron voilà a besoin aussi de rassurer
sa majorité en ce moment au royaume uni
il ya une énorme crise de confiance sur
l'europe en général
cameron a réussi à déjouer le plan le
piège que lui dresser sa majorité pour
organiser un référendum sur l'avenir de
la grande bretagne dans l'union
européenne
on n'en est plus là mais les tensions
sont là elles sont connues un pour les
britanniques
cameron a encore dit ce week-end dieu
merci on n'est pas dans la zone euro
alors vous dites il n'est pas le seul à
attaquer ses partenaires européens il ya
un peu des des attaques ou des who des
inquiétudes qui viennent un peu du du
monde entier ce que le reste du monde a
raison aujourd'hui de s'inquiéter de ce
qui se passe dans la zone euro pas la
vérité c'est que les européens d'abord
un première chose le temps de l'europe
c'est pas le temps des marchés
financiers les marchés financiers
réagissent à la mi au millième de
seconde
les européens pour prendre une décision
il faut se réunir ça prend du temps et
après il faut mettre en oeuvre les
décisions et la priorité c'est ça le 21
juillet les marchés sanctionnent la
devant la lenteur des décisions
européennes
mais ça on pourra jamais aller plus vite
que les marchés donc la vérité c'est que
déjà les européens s'entendent le 21
juillet ils ont pris des décisions
importantes et on est début octobre le
plan le plan daide pour la grèce le
deuxième plan dette n'est toujours pas
ratifié donc forcément tout le monde en
profite et les marchés les premiers est
ce qu'on peut espérer qu'il soit ratifié
un jour se planque
tout porte à croire que maintenant que
les allemands ont levé la l'obstacle
majeur d'inquiétude majeure bon il ya
deux ou trois pays encore à convaincre
je pense qu'on devrait y arriver mais le
problème c'est que déjà on est trop tard
dans le temps des marchés trop tard par
avec tout ce qui s'est passé cet été
alors en attendant les
ça ne va pas bien du tout en grèce la
situation semble s'aggraver de jour en
jour on va aller justement à athènes
avec la population grecque dans quelques
minutes françois beaudonnet sera sur ce
plateau avec une députée et grecs chef
de la délégation grecque du ppe ici au
parlement européen mais d'abord ce
reportage de germain andrieu qui a voulu
comprendre pourquoi est ce que l'argent
avait autant de mal à rentrer dans les
caisses de l'état
regardez ce reportage signé germans
andrieu et rallye de mamoun ce sont des
irréductibles un collectif avec un nom
qui sonne comme un slogan je ne paie pas
ce soir ils ont pris d'assaut ce péage
au nord d'athènes
et pour tous le passage est gratuit on
n'accepte pas la dette parce que vous
n'en est pas responsable et nous voulons
un système différent nous voulions juste
sortir de ce système d'impôt
exceptionnel ni de taxes supplémentaires
la méthode choisie est radical leur
message
un appel à la résistance pour lutter
contre les mesures d'austérité mises en
place par le gouvernement ne paient pas
de taxes ne paient pas de péage ne
paient pas une nouvelle fois ce que vous
avez déjà payé non ces choses ont déjà
été payées repayer plusieurs fois et
c'est le gouvernement les partis
politiques qui ont tout dilapidé la
corruption n'est pas seulement la fraude
fiscale le marché noir bref l'économie
souterraine
c'est près d'un tiers du produit
intérieur brut de la grèce
au coeur du placard le quartier
touristique d'athènes la crise est déjà
visible dans certaines rues plus d'une
boutique sur trois a mis la clé sous la
porte pour faire face aux impôts de plus
en plus élevés plusieurs commerçants ont
choisi de ne pas tous déclaré vous voyez
ma caisse je ne sais même pas sur quel
bouton appuyer pour l'allumer c'est
tragique
je pense qu'il faut peser les choses si
certaines taxes tu peut les éviter en ne
faisant pas de facture tu le fais
surtout depuis les nouvelles taxes
tu évalues et c'est juste de ne pas
faire des factures
après chacun prend ses responsabilités
ici la fraude fiscale n'est pas un choix
pour tous ces petits commerçants
c'est plutôt une question de survie
c'est simple on négocier avec le client
et bien sûr ça dépend du client
les grandes chaînes de vêtements font
des factures car elles n'ont pas le
choix
mais pour nous petits commerces et plus
simple on est loin de contrôler et alors
vous vous le faites mais bien sûr on n'a
pas le choix
en tant que petite entreprise j'ai plus
de 5000 euros de taxes alors que ma
société sébacées moins qu'une seule
alors là encore les factures n'existe
plus vous voyez aller cachais en bas à
ma caisse mêlée fermée depuis deux mois
il faut dire que depuis 2010 la tva est
passée de 19 à 21%
alors pour faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses de l'état la priorité
du gouvernement
voici le bâtiment de la zoé la brigade
spéciale pour lutter contre la fraude
fiscale
à l'intérieur un centre d'appels pour la
délation mais aujourd'hui un seul agent
est à son poste à cause des grèves
écoutez madame moi j'ai beaucoup de
travail dites moi exactement ce que vous
voulez attendez moi je suis tout seul g8
nîmes qui sonne la comment je fais pour
répondre à autant me demande à la fois
vous savez c'est une injustice sociale
par exemple quand un retraité gagne 300
euros par mois et qu'ils voient tous les
autres qui met la tva dans leurs poches
il se dit c'est impossible c'est tout 19
me dénonciation par an plus de 300
appels chaque jour et au maximum trois
personnes pour enregistrer toutes les
plaintes ce qu'ils appellent sont en
colère ils reçoivent un salaire paye de
plus en plus d'impôts mais n'ont pas le
choix
contrairement aux professions libérales
donc là c'est une station service qui
n'a pas fait de factures là c'est un
médecin encore un médecin est là c'est
quelqu'un qui reçoit des loyers mais qui
ne déclarent pas il faut quand même
savoir qu'en grèce la fraude fiscale
c'est un sport national quand tu
téléphones pour un prix tu as toujours
dos répond l'une avec la tva et l'autre
sens il faudrait alors renforcer les
contrôles et pour ça il faut des agents
en permanence et surtout bien payés
renforcer les équipes et les contrôles
sur le terrain la seule solution pour
éviter un cercle vicieux
mais là encore le gouvernement doit
composer avec les coupes budgétaires
annoncées pour 2012
un reportage à athènes signé germain
andrieu alors nous avons été rejoints
sur ce plateau par marietta giannakou
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne du groupe ppe vous êtes de
nationalité grecque vous avez été élu à
plusieurs reprises le parlement national
grec
quand on voit ce reportage et qu'on
comprend je dirais l'ampleur de la
fraude fiscale on a le sentiment que ce
n'est pas quelque chose de conjoncturel
mais que c'est quelque chose de culturel
est ce que c'est la fraude fiscale est
ce que on peut lutter contre est ce que
ça peut changer
l'internement mais c'est pas que c'est
pas qu'il tire lcc sont certes un
millier qui ne payent pas les dalsky
love qu'ils doivent eux à payer à l'état
mais la plupart des gens ce sont des
travailleurs dont les
et la fortune l'argent c'est très clair
c'est ce qu'ils ont sont des salariés
ils peuvent pas cacher on ne peut rien
cacher mais quand même quand on voit ce
qui se passe par exemple dans les
magasins de ce qu'on a vu dans ce
reportage qui montre très bien
on sait que c'est pareil dans deux
restaurants est ce que c'est ce que ça
peu est-ce que c'est des choses qui
peuvent changer note également la telma
mais la plupart des grecs paient les
impôts qu'ils doivent payer mais à
l'autre côté avec les taxes avec les tv
a augmenté à 23 mai dans sept à 23 ans
les taxes la tva alors vous comprenez
bien que ça devient trop dire que nous
lui travaille pour l'état ce que vous
dites c'est que c'est finalement normal
que les gens payent pas parce que les
taxes sont trop élevés non mais moi je
crois que si on allait vos élèves on
élève les taxes à la fin on arrive à un
point où en prêt - de l'argent par
exemple cette année
dans les caisses de
de l'état était entré le même argent
qu'elle était mineure alors marché est
mort les magasins ferment un plus des 4
80 mille entreprises étaient fermés
cette année est naturellement il y a
beaucoup plus d exploitation il y a on
voit un espoir
naturellement il y a des petites
entreprises avec des innovations qui
font des exploitations mais en général
la vie commerciale n'existe plus et ça
c'est la faute je dirais des plans de
rigueur successifs selon vous moi je
crois à quai on a on ne peut pas aller
loin avec ses plans d'austérité
naturellement il faut des mesures
d'austérité parce que quand on a un
dette comme
il y à gré c'est quand on a un déficit
aussi alors d'internement ils font des
mesures d'austérité mais il faut des
mesures de développement aussi il faut à
faire marcher un marché permettez-moi à
dire alors qu'après la grèce en tout cas
il faut pas l'étouffer exactement ça
c'est le grand problème on aura plus
d'argent à payer et je vais vous dire
que vous voyez le manifestant mais la
majorité des grecs ne parlent pas ils
sont très fâchés parce qu'il ne vient
pas aux manifestations mais ils sont
très fâchés et ils n'ont pas l'argent
payé parce que chaque semaine quelque
chose d'autre vient alors le
gouvernement dit il n'y a
on prend pas d'autres mesures cette
année est de jouer après on a
naturellement au la lettre k est l'état
un programme pareil
altro caf ou quand même juste rappeler
que c'est ce sont des agents de du fmi
de la banque centrale européenne et les
biches en panne
un principe classique à
je ne sais pas si ça avait vraiment
marché d'abb des différents pays alors
là twitter vont parler je vous propose
qu'on écoute une question c'est de
coutume dans cette émission est une
question qui vous est posée depuis
athènes c'est par un syndicaliste
grecque
on les écoute c'est justement à propos
de la troïka rico t il à politique la
troîka va appliquer dans notre pays est
sans issue les mesures qu'ils prennent
sont non seulement injustes les actions
aussi inefficace car ne sortent pas de
la crise son contraire est la renforce
elle crée la récession le chômage bref
c'est un cercle vicieux
bon alors c'est tout le problème c'est
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
qu'on est il est la présidente
deux fonctionnaires britanniques
allaient fonctionner bon mais c'est tout
le problème
est ce qu'on est en train est ce que
c'est un cercle vicieux est ce qu on
demande en plus d'austérité à la grèce
on est en train en train de tuer la
grèce et finalement comme vous le disiez
l'argent ne rentre pas alors qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire
il faut relâcher un peu la pression où
il faut continuer l'austérité une fois
un p arrêtez avec les taxes
par exemple on a mis on avait 13 % dans
les hôtels au secteur touristique etc et
dans les restaurants
on l'a fait 23% alors fils d'un pêcheur
et puis il ya personnes au restaurant il
est de toute façon il n'y a pas de
facture donc écouter quelque chose qui
qui est ou le montrer c'est pas quelque
chose que tout le monde fait il faut
dire la vérité moi je sors en grèce je
suis un des vendredis jusqu'à lundi est
arrivé de ne même pas donné de factures
jamais jamais vous êtes toujours à bien
dans toute ma vie non par exemple je ne
sais pas parce que je suis une personne
inconnue je ne sais pas mais c'était pas
jamais arrivé alors c'est pas tout le
monde qui fait en tout cas tous les
témoignages des touristes français ou
autres qui vont en grèce et disent tous
qu'ils ont jamais de facture quand ils
vont dans un restaurant écoutez les
grecs sont obligés je ne sais pas qu'est
ce qu'ils font avec les touristes
mais les grecs sont obligés d'avoir des
des factures quand ils font la
déclaration des taxes à l'état
alors comme ça on demande toujours des
facteurs
naturellement il faut faire quelque
chose pour renforcer au niveau 2 des
impôts jouer parce que l'émission touche
à sa fin je voudrais qu en quelques mots
vous nous disiez est-ce que vous en tant
que grecque est ce que vous êtes
confiante est ce que vous pensez que le
pays va s'en sortir il faut à la place
qu'il faut
mais il faut un plan d'austérité mais en
même temps il faut que faire quelque
chose pour pour investir il faut la
licence à ce que les prix la croissance
est le plus grand problème à ce moment
là en grèce c'est le chômage mais quand
aulas de chômage on n'a pas de l'argent
font sociale cades
vous comprenez absolument c'est
exactement comme ça alors s'il faut pas
lancer il faut équilibrer les deux un
train équilibre est un train un plan
d'austérité et un effort pour le
développement merci beaucoup d'avoir
témoigné ici sur le plateau d' europe
hebdo c'est la fin de cette émission
pour cette semaine on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec kathia gilder ici
au parlement européen d'ici là bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires